a battle royale mode might be coming to
battlefield 2042 assassin's creed could
be getting a god of war styled expansion
and more
tom henderson a long-time journalist
covering the game's industry has
suggested that battlefield 2042's
rumored battle royale mode may be on the
way henderson notes in a recent youtube
video that the battle royale mode for ea
and dice's first person shooter will be
coming in the very near future he does
not mention any specific dates or launch
windows however he does clarify that it
won't surface at least within the next
six months in the meantime some players
have started trying to make their own br
style games in portal and others have
discovered that you can pet the dog or
your ranger in multiplayer henderson
goes on to speak about the next game in
the battlefield series after 2042 saying
he's heard it will be even more like an
overwatch style hero based shooter
specifically he shares that a former
developer with the battlefield franchise
told him the next game has bands of
specialist fighting rather than the
individual specialists in 2042 that
don't have factions
and that's not all henderson has
reported on it was also mentioned that
assassin's creed valhalla's next
expansion could potentially be larger
than both of the game's previous story
dlcs combined the content is expected to
be around 40 hours of additional content
with henderson stating that it will be a
god of war styled expansion whatever
that means earlier this year dataminers
uncovered something related to valhalla
called dawn of ragnarok which might
explain the god of war connection and
suggests that valhalla is planning to
get even more fantastical with its story
after alluding to it earlier this year
ubisoft has announced its first project
within the non-fungible token or nft
ecosystem and it's titled ubisoft courts
an nft is a one-of-a-kind item that
exists on a blockchain that gives buyers
digital ownership rights
courts will wrap up in-game cosmetics
into their own nfts each of which will
have a unique serial number and history
of owners these items called digits can
then be freely traded between players
for agreed upon prices with a natural
economy forming around these
transactions and the scarcity of items
if this sounds familiar it should as
it's essentially what valve has been
doing with the sea marketplace for games
like counter-strike global offensive
dota 2 and more for years the program
which is still in beta is currently only
supported by ghost recon breakpoint on
pc and only available in certain regions
despite using a decentralized blockchain
called tesos the blockchain makes use of
proof of stake as opposed to the
energy-hungry proof-of-work blockchains
such as bitcoin and ethereum leading
ubisoft to call its venture energy
efficient in case you didn't know it can
cost an extreme amount of energy to
produce an nft and comes with a major
cost to the environment which may be why
ubisoft is stressing the energy
efficient angle of tesos this is the
first step in what ubisoft says will be
a four-year venture into blockchain
technology and the company's pursuit of
its own metaverse according to quartz's
press release no other games have been
announced with support for these digits
but given ubisoft's substantially large
library it's perhaps only a matter of
time before that changes ubisoft isn't
the only publisher looking at blockchain
technologies and nfts in particular with
ea and grand theft auto owner take 2
also taking an interest
the first full-length trailer for the
new halo tv series is coming this week
during the game awards but ahead of that
a new teaser video is here to get us
excited filming on the halo tv series
wrapped in july this year following some
delays related to covid but the show is
now in post-production and teams are
knee-deep in finishing the visual
effects and other post-production
efforts ahead of its release on
paramount plus in 2022
what do you think of what we've seen of
the show so far and what are you hoping
to see of it during the game awards let
me know in the comments below and be
sure to leave a like and subscribe so
you don't miss your next gamespot news
you